[inaudible]
tourist, a word, a bucket list item,
and on the southeast coast of Mexico,
big business life here revolves
around the tourist town,
whether man, woman, or beast
there aren't mailed to restock.
It's also what they call
that feeling in your gut.
You get after you ingest too much of
the local water. I arrived as a tourist,
I headed to Cozumel or
as the straight face.
Send your order selling
information upon arrival,
put it [inaudible] a slice Doria.
That history goes back to the Yuca Tech.
Maya as their civilization expanded
some Mayans packed up their language and
architecture and traveled the route de
Maya up to this wide flat peninsula that
you got done. So the ruins
here are a bit younger,
which doesn't stop the duty stats to
generate size about 10 times as popular as
fabled decal. That's all
history like the men said,
but it's not all in the
distant past. Until recently,
the Caribbean coast of Mexico
was pretty undeveloped,
not small houses with a few open lots,
kind of undeveloped but fresh jungle,
kind of undeveloped, savage, solid back.
The very salvage k, very flat,
very Mayan [inaudible] became one of
Mexico's two newest states in 1974
some local still speak. You get tech.
I'm told you can even practice
the language if you get
the right person to open
up. I didn't have much luck.
Might have something to do with my
mind being limited to shock and Balaam,
but much like you and me,
most of these smiling faces around
here flock to these beach towns.
Thanks to big booty, small snorkel tours,
dive tours, tours to the ruins. Oh,
and don't forget your tee
shirt and Wigley Turtle.
Yeah.
Have Fun. Be Safe and bring
your pesos. Fellow Trista
[inaudible].